with us now is the Ukrainian ambassador
to the UK van impristaiko hi
um how was the weekend for you
as for many many people especially in
Ukraine and Russia watching TV and
trying to understand what is actually
happening
and what is happening
there is no shortage of opinions and
experts ideas what why who who won the
politician precaution careful
businessman Prego military commander
pre-guardian but the most important
thing is that Putin is weakened so it's
like the spiders in a jar the one who
will get out of it will be wounded and
weakened
need to be wary of people like progosian
be careful what you wish for is what we
would say here in the west oh we're not
wishing him to win all of the my enemies
of our world so we have no mistake but
the problem is in in Russian that they
already started looking for the better
sort of project
will give him how he was treated by
people in rostov like a rock star look
at the the bureaucracy of the whole
system on the half of this the security
Council was available immediately to
support Putin on TV look at military
commanders he had no no opposition he
was marching to the Moscow stopped or
200 kilometers from Moscow and oligarchs
nothing can be done in Russia without a
regards approval support so all of them
all the system is looking for the better
through the way out how much of that
though was theater were he actually uh
with his men
um depends two and a half thousand
twenty five thousand depending on who
you uh listen to actually have marched
on Moscow it certainly would have been
Bloodshed significant Bloodshed on both
sides I agree he was probably and his
Masters were probably thinking that the
system will collapse or they will have
better deal than they had now we don't
know yet what was the deal why he turned
back but actually they were expecting
that the better deal will be offered we
have to to watch what will happen to the
military commanders of chief of defense
and defense minister
who appeared today on TV showing that he
is still still in the history when that
was recorded that that footage could
have been maybe maybe but that's that's
what is actually happening remember
garbage in his last year he survived
military coup only to be replaced in
what four months
it's um it's such a stressful time
um for um I know that you have family in
Ukraine what sort of impact is this
having on the people of Ukraine how
where are they of what's Happening
everybody knows what's happening and we
were watching and you know it was quite
a wise move on our ministry of Defense
side when they offered Russian soldiers
to leave the positions to actually to
clean up their own house
so they offered them to go back home and
try to do something so they can actually
save their lives but now the words is
back
never stopped we took some Advantage off
of the situation of the the
mismanagement to the Russian side what
did you manage to do yeah a couple of
kilometers here and there but we're
still probing they were trying to
understand where defenses are weaker to
actually engage with everything we have
has this effect
begun in owners tonight
it's already begun it's not as
spectacular as everybody first of all
the ukrainians wanted to see it but we
hope that as through these tries and
attempts everywhere around the the whole
thousand kilometers and we'll find the
weaker place where we will engage
everything
How concerned are you about progosian um
the Wagner leader going into Exile in
Belarus which is just to the north of
your country of course also suggestions
that nuclear weapons have been put in
position there from Putin to the the
Belarusian president the nuclear weapons
is a real threat not just for Ukraine
but for everybody on this planet we are
worrying about our own Nuclear Station
we've been mined to to best of our
knowledge so we have to be careful there
I do not believe that the forces which
precaution bringing with him to Belarus
will will threaten our flights because
we were keeping forces strong enough
there just to build Russian forces and
some Russians interesting point is
is growing its importance he was
planning all this along to you know to
become something more important than
just build a Russian leader that's one
of the explanations why he agreed to
become a unionist state with Russia so
now is his best times of his whole
political career
so you too I'm interested to explore
further when you talk about the pay
masters of progosian who do you think
that is
obviously there are oligars who actually
not happy with with the results of the
war some of them by the way would rather
see escalation than discolation but
that's different what they are not happy
with that they're losing and everything
they were talking about the sanctions
are not working now they are working so
they took enormous risk in their system
to support preggers a progression
doesn't want to end the war
no that's what I'm saying that some of
them would probably go and escalate the
words they are still our enemies that's
not what you're concerned about we're
concerned but at the same time we
understand that there is no other way
just to finish up this work all the red
lines were already crossed the new ones
which were drawn also been crossed there
is a time where we fight and happily
we're receiving the enough weapons and
support from the West look at this
London conference on economic recovery
of Ukraine billions and billions of
dollars were promised
big day tomorrow for Ukraine it is tell
me more
ukrainians will you know that's
something we will be preparing for quite
quite a while we will see how everything
will go
um and as far as lukashenko is concerned
do you feel that
um the leader of the Wagner group
pregosian going to his country has
strengthened his position
I don't believe that regarding is is
that important especially anymore he
played his own role he almost brought
down the president I know at least he
tried to go there and he scared the
everybody in his own system and some
people were obviously supporting him but
we have to watch for another leader to
come and precaution was not the only one
who was quite popular
and then been just sent in obscurity it
was the guy who was running this 2014
Rebellion gherkin now he's a minor
figure on his own local TVs one of you
guys going to go on the table with the
Russians
as soon as this table will be
established somewhere in between the
Ukraine and the Russian official borders
even if you move
you move to their own border
known to be
a problem with that border but the
problem is it's quite weak definition
what will happen to Russia there will be
a huge danger to us all especially if
they collapse it will be even more
danger but that's what we prepare to do
we have to fight we have to push them
out to their own borders and maybe maybe
they will just clean out their own
system and try to build something better
than they used to have
so the um the bottom line is for
ukrainians for president zielinski that
you will not see an end to this war
until you have recovered all of the land
that was taken by Russia including
Crimea let me put this way this is what
we are planning to do we are planning to
fight we have enough resources to do so
we're very uh very aware of the losses
where we're we're having we understand
how difficult on top of this but at the
same time that's the best in our recent
history the best chance of us to build
our own independent state and then live
there
did you allow yourself at any stage over
the weekend a rice smile from what was
going on in Moscow
um in February of last year
um you were threatened that your Capital
would be taken uh in 24 to 48 hours uh
over the weekend
um in a 108 degree turnaround it was
Moscow that was threatened yeah dark
irony here they started with two three
days to take over here but now they
defended their own capital and talking
about civilian war in their own hands
that's what happened to each and every
aggressor and they have to understand it
was the ukrainians were happy that is
happening I don't believe they were
happy but there's some relief because I
saw your commander and forgive me I
can't remember his name who's fighting
in back mode he was sitting watching the
videos eating popcorn yeah that's what
ukrainians all of them stored lots and
lots of popcorn to watch this this drama
unfolding very unfortunately for us it
was very well and very short-lived at
least we hope that we will see something
like that in the future which will
distract the most of the forces of the
Ukrainian frontlines that's what we want
and that's the idea to have the
distraction on their own turf and so you
can bring forward to your advances
listen I would be happy if our security
service is so good that we actually
created the whole precaution and you
know it helped and supported I'd like to
think this way but I believe that their
own internal problems which we will take
advantage of for sure and how worried
are you about what's happening with the
nuclear power plants
this is the biggest power plant in
Europe so if there are nations who knows
what is that the the nuclear disaster
Ukraine one of very few of those ones so
we understand what would happen and
that's why president zielinski is trying
to to reach to everybody the leaders
around the globe and try to tell them
that guys we have to do something before
it's too late the interesting question
what to do right now just before I let
you go is this another pivotal Moment In
The Wall I believe it is very important
was it pivotal not we will see just in a
couple of days but I believe that this
is very important the the leader of
Russia is so weakened that they will
have to rethink their strategy that is
for sure what do you expect to happen I
hope that very soon this something will
happen with the military command
and then don't forget that they have the
elections 24 it's not just on you only
or us by the way or United States
Russians also have it we might see the
different result from what was expected
by a Russian system there is no sevens
or Aids term for Putin I hope